you know peace day so you know every got
very rudely baseball and basketball and
we won I made sure my mom dad says you
missing pieces
where's food ranked I lose my money out
what's your perfect feats are like what
my perfect pieces of meat loaves for
pizza that's just powder that's just
paper or something like that right you
know eat real food man just do it you
know the right way mmm make sure we
[ __ ] around with like a like a
meatlovers but I call turkey and chicken
stuff oh yeah let's do this sauce it up
all white lips all right
what about like something jalapeno
something like that y'all getting off
about how the pain feel I like spinach I
like mushrooms now it's this [ __ ] dead
like a lot of rich [ __ ] been he lately
I've been around truffle oh yeah the
truffle
also truffle in it that doesn't make
everything all right so we were talking
they went shopping yeah and you're gonna
bring like your childhood need lovers
Pizza back to life so this is gonna be
the first time I've ever made pizzas in
here stone before severe just think oh
yeah yeah man that's the only way to
make on them I feel that guy in there
yeah yeah so now a good thing and now
it's kind of relatively round use your
fingers and dot around the build your
crust build that all the way around
that's where it's ticket so that's where
I lost you I ripped it yeah it's gonna
happen lay the whole thing out in the
middle yeah and then use the bottom of
the label just to make circles and swirl
it around yeah that's how you'd be done
you want some mushrooms on there take a
little stuff in here you got mushrooms
peppers onions jalapeno you know what
ma'am I'm not really a Benji I'm gonna
cut my piece of but then peppers
sometimes they give it a little bit of
flavor so I'm just gonna add a tan a
little Tang them now he bout to do the
street Louis Freddie they landed it
monster pizza
yeah do it the thick pies some dinner
pretty Gibbs Street lovers Pizza around
Fairfax I don't like the new turtles dog
y'all [ __ ] that Ninja Turtles movie up
well I need a dog cuz I was watching
secret of the rules and the original
[ __ ] like that man and then [ __ ] lot
size man turns to 12 feet tall at 12
foot tall turtle go hop in the sewer my
new the need is just throwing cars they
what the [ __ ] we can't throw to turn
into turtle no car dog that's [ __ ]
you